hello everybody I hope you're either had
a coffee or you getting a coffee and
then coming back to hear my talk because
during my studies as a psychology
Bachelor student I also i did an
experiment on attention and the
circadian rhythm and it turned out that
exactly doing this time the attention
span the cognitive performance is about
forty percent less than at the peak
hours so I hope that I will be
stimulating enough for you and I can
promise you that I will not try to
convince anybody not to use SPSS that's
totally not what my talks about is
actually more about simulation and
agent-based modeling and yeah that gets
me to what am I doing here well first of
all like the talk is going to be like
roughly divided in three parts the first
will be a small introduction to
psychology and kind of different
approaches and I will be talking about
like a more specific one that is not so
common and it is that of computerized
thought experiments and for that python
is a great tool mature to make the
abstract tangible and in the end i will
give an example of well this agent-based
simulation and that i program myself
from scratch and show that just to give
you know like a frame of reference
cognition in the way that i will be
using the term it's used in many
different ways that are tuned by like
ambivalent in my opinion and that's why
like I try to redefine it and make this
definition like tangible with the
simulation is the way that I am kind of
the code the interpretation that I
prefer is by motto veena motto ghana
vanilla
and they describe cognition as holistic
aspect of a self-reproducing living
system which can be a human being for
example but it also like just a bacteria
you know anything which can be defined
by a living system cyclical property of
self maintenance and therefore survival
through the processing of information
and the processing of information to
further one's own survival that seems to
me should be something that all of you
know about as as people working with
data to also like making your money with
it so like to put it in a really simple
way this definition says basically life
is a loop feeding itself literally like
so but the key of the presentation is
not a master this model of cognition but
actually the bridging of the gap between
two disciplines and kind of my
inspiration that I got as a psychology
student to learn programming and to use
that to come up with something unique
and then I actually ended up applying
for a master's program in computer
science and they accepted me because the
former requirement was a natural science
degree and I have a Bachelor of Science
and I had to like study incredibly much
and and recover a lot of courses but now
I'm finally through with all of that
I've three semesters ago but now I'm a
proper master student and well yeah
adding the computational element to to
my work despite at a time having a
completely non computational background
my name is Tito's van coller and I told
you the other things already that are on
the slide currently I live in lugano
switzerland and you can see this
beautiful panorama
lugano it's pretty tiny I mean it's the
capital of Italian speaking Switzerland
ticino but it has some pretty cool
things there I mean it has Europe's
fastest supercomputer which is actually
the sixth fastest in the world has this
really nice University which is not well
known but informatics department is
really young actually so I only ten
years old but it was founded by people
from ETH Zurich and especially the
master's program is especially like it's
really great and there's only like four
to like 25 students and in any of the
classes and I don't know any other
university that offers such a great you
know ratio from student to professor and
the professors are incredible like
researchers and their provide some
special people they're like my some one
slide about personal things I love
skiing backcountry skiing which you see
in the middle and the top slide and it
has been so since I'm very young and I
have a tiny cute dog but you know that's
just random stuff maybe that you know
gets you less tired if the coffee is not
working yet so psychology many people
you know have kind of weird things like
they ask me you know so you study
psychology or well that's in the past
now but so isn't psychologists like
somebody like a plumber for the soul and
then they like and they kind of kind of
mix up all these terms like psychologist
psychotherapist psychiatrist and psycho
and really I mean psychology is science
and people that study psychology don't
end up a psychotherapist that's maybe
twenty percent and psychiatrist people
that have a medical education and not
this psychology as a science and well I
studied psychology and it is like
according to wikipedia which many
professors don't like but I like it it's
kind of a kind of looking glass on kind
of the greatest common denominator
psychology is the study of behavior and
mind embracing our aspects of human
experience it is an academic discipline
and an appliance science which seeks to
understand
vigils and groups by establishing great
general principles and researching
specific cases why do more psychologists
need to learn Python the obvious answer
which this talk will not be about is
python has become the go-to statistical
tool how you might know I mean came to a
conference about it and all other
options mostly suck maybe our doesn't
suck so much but I mean mainly people in
psychology they use stuff like spss and
as like total crap and the not so
obvious answer is programming languages
sorry just give me a second terms of
water programming languages are the
perfect tool to describe processes and
the mind is a process the inter magna
intermingling inside the mind or the
intermingling between minds that can all
be described as distributed processes
and this is what I want to lead up to
that simulation and modeling and you
know programming is a really good way of
of making these processes tangible and
you know historically classically
psychology also the methods and
psychology are tend to be divided like
at a fundamental level into quantitative
and qualitative methods quantitative I
mean we just heard about for example in
the last last talk it's pretty similar
in psychology evaluate hypotheses
usually in an experiment try to set up
the experiment so that it's you know
like not really ambivalent and that you
don't have a lot of noise and just to
give an example there was a really nice
experiment done at Yale and it showed
basically that something as simple as
you know whether a person is handed a
hot or a cut cup in an elevator going up
to a room in which the person will then
be interviewing another person
statistically like shows relevant
statistically relevant and deaf
Francis in the way that we evaluate
character in other people I mean and
that's a pretty incredible result in my
opinion and that's like a typical
example of how you would conduct a
quantitative quantitative psychological
study try to have as little kind of
diverging you know aspect of the
experiments as possible and have one key
thing that's different in this case you
know and the elevator ride the guy was
just you know pertaining to tie shoes
and gave the cup to the to the person
that was being experimented on the
problem with that like approach in
general is that it like it tends to only
like you can only make things clear that
are like pretty reductionistic in nature
and you know great complexity is
difficult to to to approach with that so
and then you have the qualitative which
tries to deal with the unquantifiable it
employs methods like observation hidden
or participatory like open participatory
and the research tends to be more
descriptive in nature and I try to kind
of come up with models but it's really
kind of not the approach that is common
in the Natural Sciences I'm a good
example is the gang it's a book by
Thrasher it means quite a while ago 1927
and it is a careful analysis of Chicago
gangs and basically here looks very
closely how about urban design and like
geography and effects gangs and also
gang economies for example and the thing
is that this kind of research is
extremely work intensive and there's a
lot of procedure to it and still it's
you know it's it's can be discussed how
valid it is and and it needs a lot of
foundation and theory and the theory is
really like there's many different
that don't agree with each other and
well that's it that's not what my talk
is about I want to talk about thought
experiments in Python and programming is
great because for for this purpose
because um it is very good at narrowly
different like I mean well that's sorry
I got mixed up so basically programming
is already great at narrowly defined and
highly specifiable tasks like system
management's and all the kind of stuff
that you can automate and it's very kind
of clearly laid out but less obviously
so at least I mean when I guess like I
don't think of this approach that is
that common it's also a great
exploratory and descriptive tool I mean
you're all kind of deal with that but in
the general computer science community
I'm not so sure if if people like play
around with notebooks and kind of trying
to make models of whatever they're
interested in and see how you know like
what comes out and thought experiments
are devices of the imagination used to
investigate the nature of things and I
mean classical examples Maxwell's demon
Einstein you know imagining trying like
riding this beam of light or like
Schrodinger's cat for example and even
literature like this dystopian novella
and brave new world they're all fat
experiments and they are all kind of
trying to make some idea make it more
tangible and formulated in a way that is
coherent and make it accessible to
others so
and programming is especially well
suited for this purpose in my opinion it
can lay bare the dependencies of a
system and the well written program is a
program in which it is very clear how
the components interact what influences
want and what constrains what it forces
you to be very explicit about the
interrelations similar to you know what
mathematical description does but
actually it's more it is a dynamic
description that kind of execute in time
so it has more richness to it in my
opinion and so for creating this kind of
mechanized thought experience
implemented in Python in my case one can
make the abstract tangible and make it
reproducible I mean you can just
download my ipad for notebook later and
run it and then you have it reproduced
and you can change things change things
and play around so the practical example
I mean I've pretty much described it
already I mean it's i programmed an
agent-based simulation simulation from
scratch you know trying to make clear
this idea of cognition as kind of
survival through the processing of
information and at the time it was of
course a great excuse to spend more time
programming because i had just kind of
started learning python on my own and i
got really interested in and but i mean
for this thesis i spent like months just
you know programming and and and it was
really a cool project and that was quite
some time ago so um but in this context
could I chose you know cognition because
i think it is used to an event it's used
to ambivalently and psychology and
neuroscience like there was at the time
was a so discussion about like cognitive
enhancement and how it is like maybe
morally bad or good or and i kind of
thought so what is cognition relieved
cognition like to me it was obvious that
you know more cognition
it's necessarily good because I don't
know it was just an obvious thing and
then the more I looked into it it seemed
always less clear what cognition really
is you know traditionally people think
of it like us hi brain functions
hierarchical thinking and abstract
reasoning and the thing is it's really
like the the border to other things and
you know like where is it grounded and
physiological reality and that's not so
clear if you really look into it and I
mean it's based on the massive amount of
complexity interrelated processes
cognition and if you think about it like
from the down up like just you know such
a simple thing as blood oxygenation as
basically it's fundamental to a proper
cognitive function and and it's
something that definitely you know
there's a factor and from the top down I
mean if you just like absolutely
theoretically identify a danger to your
physical well-being then also your your
your your body needs to react to it you
need to have a fear response you need to
you know get ready to maybe fight and
you know like run away and and and that
is all part of cognition and yeah I just
said that so this definition of Matawan
of Avila and they're actually I think
they're both biologists and they did a
lot of neuroscience research as well and
it was nineteen eighty that they came up
with this theory of autopoietic machines
that sounds really like um special but
really it's it's it's kind of like
looking at life as a loop that is
feeding itself keeping itself alive and
processing information in order to do so
and and it is that a simple level of
just a simple cell and it's also at a
level of something as complex as a human
being or even a civilization or whatever
um this is not done yet now I'm gonna
use the chance to give you a look at my
simulation and
it's not was not designed to be like
especially graphically pleasing so it's
a it's a it's basically like a grid with
Unicode and and and and it's a bit like
nostalgic reminds one of the ascii thing
is let me restart it so the agents have
all kinds of properties and they have
kind of simple cognition they have their
own representation of the world they
kind of it's based on the classical
agent-based model i'm called Sugarscape
where the agents how kind of run around
a grid and collect sugar and they need
to do so because they have a metabolism
and they burn the sugar and they need
that in order to survive and that's like
the simple model behind that and
basically then I I kind of every agent
as its own instance and it has its own
representation of the world and it has
like slightly diverging properties and
then you can see like over time how well
the different agents survive with like
different combinations of properties and
they can even have offspring and like
recombine and and and so over time you
can kind of see how a kind of evolution
happens and and and and and like the
sole thesis was about how different
obvious like factors like not obvious
but different factors that seem pretty
simple can have like a pretty clear
effect on something as simple and stupid
seeming as this really really simple
agent-based model which is not so simple
after all um
the problems that they're dying too fast
so you the thing is that you know the
last house they have the more faint they
become and you kind of see them swarming
around and and basically this is kind of
like the forest has a lot of sugar and
and you have seasons and basically the
blue part is in winter and the green
part is in spring and summer and the
growth of the sugar the regrowth is
based on that and you know if the agents
eat too much sugar at a certain place it
will not regrow for a fixed period and
there's all these kind of aspects to it
I mean if you want to play around with
it feel free to download the notebook I
don't know how much time we have left
well plenty
so
well the the whole thing is built on a
grid and every sun the grid is a tile
and the tile has certain properties like
how much sugar it has you know and it
regrows the sugar and and it interacts
with the agents so the agents can eat up
the sugar and and and here you see a
graph for example of the depletion of a
sugar cell if the if the agents eat up
all the sugar it will be like a fixed
period until it regrows again so you can
also kind of kind of see the impact of
you know if I would like just have like
a thousand agents at the same time they
will just eat up all the sugar and like
seventy percent of the population would
die and some would be able to survive
from so it's also it shows like how an
environment can sustain a certain
population and how its kind of
self-regulating and there's a lot of
interesting dynamic to it and like you
can see I used like it actually it turns
out that like there's a huge state space
and the sole thing like even with such a
small grid and and Python at a certain
point it was just too slow to properly
run it and so I had to kind of profile
the functions and and optimize some of
the functions that were most used and i
also used scion eyes and here you have
the agent model and and every agent has
like a like a fixed metabolism and I'm
kind of a heartbeat and and the thing is
that like I had different versions of
this basically in one version the agent
says they would be aging the metabolism
would get you know more intense and then
at a certain point they would just die
from age because they couldn't have with
you know like I'll keep their metabolism
anymore and there's all kinds of
different parameters that are
interesting to play with and that kind
of come back at this kind of model of
cognition and how you can kind of verify
it in an abstract and make it kind of
kind of Illustrated
yeah I think and I displayed the whole
thing with a kind of like like in HTML
and it's a it's an HTML frame that
updates itself for every step of the
simulation and that's how the
visualization that's about it I guess if
you have any questions you can ask me
now and just quickly as the last thing
thank you very much for listening you
can find this ipython notebook and the
thesis about it which is much more
detail and really well written actually
I put a lot of effort into it and like
knots and and and I think it's also nice
to read it's on github on my account and
just a bit of south advertisement if you
like what you saw or like have a nice
team that does quality work in software
development i'm now not a psychologist
anymore at least on primarily I'm a
computer scientist so do aspiring to be
and I'm looking for more practical
experience I mean I have a research
experience I've worked at noob spa
Research Institute were developed this
and then I worked at an AI Institute
where I had to work with a huge Python
code base but right now I'm looking for
something more practical in nature and
and want to learn more about really good
software development practices so if you
know of any opportunities or feel like
passing on my CV to your HR department
please come to me and I will hand
one of my many puppies here so there's a
couple of questions yeah hi thank you
for your presentation and what you told
in the beginning of the presentation was
that you want to learn more about the
cognition right so that's why you went
into programming and you use an age of
ice model what what it is teach you
about the cognition of this agents that
you that you invented or made up well it
taught me more like I mean in a way what
I noticed now also while studying
computer science there's much different
to kind of the thinking that's going on
in this kind of psychology domain it's
really the this kind of procedural pneus
of thinking and and and how one thing
follows from the other and how things
are kind of like interlinked in a way
that is mechanical and not just
associative in kind of and and and
that's what I learned from the the thing
I mean it was not it's in the end it was
just a really nice kind of toy for me
you know and it was a toy where I could
see like I could do some things and it
was enough for a bachelor thesis but it
was not some you know fundamental
research you know it's not some crazy
new thing that it's groundbreaking but
it's it's a really nice way or in my
opinion of playing with ideas and of
making things concrete and and I think
you know if you put more effort and you
know with the possibilities and
computing power that I that I just
coming with time I think you can do much
more interesting research and yeah
animation so there's a general concept
for psychology it could be interesting
that's what you're saying no no I'm
saying it's really good to combine
perspectives from different fields and
it's
it's very nice to kind of kind of kind
of get ideas and thought patterns from
different areas and combine them and
create something new and play around
with it and and I saw something that
like I mean further if there's anybody
that is a psychologist maybe it was
interesting but also I think for
computer science to me I think it is
quite a unique perspective and I just
wanted to share it with you guys Thanks
any other questions because in that case
I might be selfish and ask for myself
could you show your notebook again yeah
what exactly do you use to cause the
simulation animation to happen is that a
sort of magic that's in the notebook
itself or is that a certain package that
you're using the cool thing with the
ASCII art in both colors and all yeah
it's quite a while ago that I programmed
this but basically i use this display
frame
so basically here you see the template
and basically this template is
dynamically updated with every step and
then it's displayed like it sits with
every step of the simulation it's
dynamically updated and ipython notebook
just displays it that way and and and
basically it clears the output at the
end of every step and then it and we
draws it but it's not perceptible so it
seems like a then I'm like updating for
loop if you have all which was the old
frame and puts in you any place yeah
okay it's a trick I've never seen which
is very cool thanks for sharing that
yeah if I could have one last applause
for our dear speaker